SANDEEP DINESH: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't get
to "Meet Anthos!"
stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's jump right into it.
This session is about how Anthos
helps solve three challenges
that enterprises face--
minimizing risk,
increasing innovation,
and growing and
retaining talented teams.
Minimizing risk often involves
creating and enforcing
complex IT policy,
building robust guardrails
in your environments, and
restricting where data can go
and what services can be used.
That's not the fun part.
Developers want to
spend time and energy
delivering value to customers
and embracing new technologies.
For example, you may want to
adopt a hybrid cloud strategy
by adding multiple
cloud platforms along
with your existing
on-prem deployment.
Each new environment brings
unique development challenges,
security constraints, and its
own quirks and idiosyncrasies.
The more differences you
add, the greater the risk.
Anthos comes to the rescue with
a unified platform that can
run across clouds and on-prem.
Your team can focus on building
and operating applications
instead of learning
the differences
of each environment.
Anthos is built on
industry-standard open source
technology, so the risk of
lock-in is greatly minimized.
Anthos those lets you
manage and control
these different environments
under a single pane of glass.
And with Anthos
config management,
you can define, enforce,
and track policy
across your hybrid environments
with a centralized Git
repository.
Along with minimizing
risk, Anthos
lets you innovate faster.
With Anthos, developers can
write serverless applications
that run in Google
Cloud, on-prem,
and even on other clouds
by using Cloud Run.
Your teams can focus on
delivering value instead of
wasting time with cluster
management and Kubernetes
primitives.
Anthos also makes it easy to
enhance the observability,
security, and control
of containerized and
non-containerized applications
with the Istio Powered Service
Mesh.
And Anthos Migrate helps
you convert physical servers
or VMs directly into
containers without requiring
additional steps,
complexity, or labor,
making it easy to
containerize and manage
all of your workloads.
By bringing together serverless,
Service Mesh, and migration
technologies into one platform,
Anthos empowers your teams
to be more innovative
and productive.
Finally, finding
and retaining talent
becomes much easier
because Anthos
is based on industry-standard
open-source technologies
that more and more developers
are interacting with every day.
You can find experts
in the community who
can start contributing
on day one
instead of hiring a team
to create and maintain
complex internal infrastructure.
Skills that are
learned on the job
are more easily
transferable as well,
allowing your teams to be more
collaborative and flexible.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]